bonjour à tous à l'initiative du groupe
ump du sénat une mission commune
d'information sur l'organisation
territoriale du système scolaire a été
créée le 8 mars cette mission organisée
au sénat une table ronde en présence de
tous les syndicats de l'éducation
nationale
au menu des discussions notamment l les
expérimentations souhaité par luc chatel
et l'autonomie des établissements
scolaires on écoute tout de suite sa
table ronde
donc on passe on va passer à la deuxième
série de questions
un pardon on est de l'état et donc qui
répondent aux deux pieds sur un temps et
donc qu'on me dit qu'il serait bien que
vous répondiez aux deux questions en
même temps je les rappelle s'est
consacré donc ressources humaines de
l'établissement scolaire
la première question c'est le chef
d'établissement de rethel doit-il être
un pilote un gestionnaire ou un
coordonnateur jeu si mc des obligations
de service des enseignants sont elles
adaptées à l'école d'aujourd'hui donc
bien que les questions soient très
importante
vous essayez de rester dans les temps
qu'on a un qu'on a prévu initialement
c'est un ca 5 minutes pour répondre aux
2 questions au maximum donc
oui mais difficile quand tout le monde
soit on sélectionne donc le choix qu'on
a été fait c'est de l'entendre le
maximum je rajoute je rappelle que le
dialogue continue ensuite vous pouvez
écrire faire part de vos remarques par
écrit on vous y répondra et
éventuellement on pourra à ce moment-là
vous revoir si on leur on le juge
nécessaire permettre on souhaite un
autre rapport fin juin donc ça nous
laisse encore un peu de temps et ça vous
laisse le temps ont vu aussi de
l'évolution de nos travaux et j'en
profite pour vous dire donc on fera une
journée dont deux d'étape
le 4 mai le 4 mai au matin ici au sénat
et à laquelle bien sûr vous serez
conviés donc pas qui on commence quand
vous voulez
la première question le chef
d'établissement doit-il être un pilote
un gestionnaire un coordonnateur jeu
nous intervenons en tant que
professionnels de santé bien souvent sur
plusieurs établissements de ce nom en
relation avec différents différents
chefs d'établissement nous avons envie
aussi même de l'appeler bien souvent un
leader parce que la tête de son équipe
éducative son style et son choix vont
influencer a dit quotidienne de
l'établissement et se pose la question
alors je vais peut-être orienter la
question par rapport à l'articulation
avec l'équipe santé je précise que
l'infirmière est sous l'autorité du chef
d'établissement
l'assistante sociale et le médecin sont
sous celle de l'inspecteur d'académie et
en ce qui nous concerne l'absence de
hiérarchie favorise la dépendance
professionnelle du médecin et donc le
rôle d'expert vis-à-vis du chef
d'établissement dans le champ de la
santé de celui talisman ont pu compter
sur la firme hier au quotidien et sur le
médecin d'éducation nationale pour pour
les situations plutôt difficile il
délègue s'est volontiers à ces
professionnels de la politique de santé
d'établissement est en tout cas une
formule gagnante nous nous paraît être
la suivante lorsque les projets
d'éducation à la santé sont plus ou
moins impulsé avec des axes données sur
le plan médical avec l'évaluation que le
médecin en mesure de proposer mais que
le chef d'établissement coordonne en
tant qu'ordinateur coordonne et soutient
l'infirmière assure le suivi
applications et le coc a un rôle
également deux pouvant engager toute
l'équipe validé développer des projets
éducatifs et partenariaux alors le chef
d'établissement dirige son équipe
le médecin se situerait par rapport
strictement aux projets de santé dans le
champ spécifique de la santé aussi bien
pour le premier que le second degré
entend plutôt que que pilote dans les
différents secteurs d'activités
médicales je précise que l'hôpital pmi
séquelles sociales la responsabilité
administrative et bien différencier de
la responsabilité médicale
donc en ce sens notre articulations ne
nous est pas spécifique
c'est quelque chose qui se retrouvent
dans les différentes administrations
je souligne part
par rapport à cette question que à
l'hôpital par exemple la voix du médecin
ne se limite pas à un simple rôle
consultatif comme c'est le cas dans les
ca des établissements compte tenu de
l'importance de la santé dans un
établissement que ce soit l'hygiène
l'ergonomie la nutrition la restauration
collective les rythmes scolaires et les
projets d'établissement ceci devrait
pouvoir être possible de prendre part au
vote et de sortir de son simple rôle
d'expert et son implication dans de
nombreux établissements n'est pas du
tout à un argument pour empêcher cette
ce projet la possibilité d'une
procuration d'une suppléance devrait
pouvoir être envisageable en particulier
avec les autres professionnels de
affirmé à rousseau sociaux de
l'établissement bah oui monsieur le
président les personnels de direction
pour les chefs d'établissement et chefs
d'établissement adjoint puisque c'est
désormais le nom de des personnels de
direction adjoint doit effectivement
être en même temps et des pilotes et des
gestionnaires et des coordonnateurs et
j'ajouterais et des pédagogues et des
médiateurs et des négociateurs et des
synthétiseurs de politiques publiques
avec sa ferme est ouvert et prudent et
audacieux je dirais simplement que le
rôle aujourd'hui et les missions des
personnels de direction sont simplement
en fait le reflet des missions qu'on
confie aux établissements qui le dirige
takia pas d'autonomie si je puis dire
professionnelle par rapport en fait à la
réalité de du fonctionnement des
développeurs et cep le ont deux
caractéristiques
la première c'est que ce sont
fondamentalement pas des structures dont
le mode de fonctionnement est
généralement hiérarchique
on part souvent de la gouvernance en là
pour le coup on est en général dans la
gouvernance
on peut dire quand on dirige un
établissement autant que fois que je
veux en fait dans la pratique et il faut
convaincre non et ça c'est une réalité
qui correspond d'ailleurs je pense à la
réalité dominante du système
d'une certaine façon
qui peut rappeler d'autres d'autres
organisations je pense dans la santé ou
finalement l'éducation la santé sont
très en parallèle sur les relations
entre les structures dirigeantes et les
praticiens le deuxième la deuxième
caractéristique c'est que on demande aux
établissements et donc quoi la direction
leur établissement un exercice quand
même absolument extraordinaire qui
demande beaucoup de qualités aujourd'hui
puisque l'on demande de résoudre
localement des problèmes qu'on ne veut
pas ou qu'on ne peut pas résoudre
nationalement donc on est supposé
pouvoir le faire au plus près
donc ça demande beaucoup de qualités
mais c'est un métier un métier
passionnant le chef d'établissement
nautile être un pilote un gestionnaire
un coordinateur dans les écoles
maternelles élémentaires
il n'y a pas de chef d'établissement il
n'existe pas ou nous je vais rappeler
tout à l'heure nous ne souhaitons pas
que l'école primaire sans reconfigurer
sur le modèle des établissements du
second degré le directeur d'école j'ai
un rôle essentiel dans le fonctionnement
des écoles
son métier il consiste à organiser la
vie de l'école certes à gérer l'école
mais il est aussi avant tout animateur
d'une équipe pédagogique et médiateur un
rôle essentiel à jouer en particulier en
direction des parents pour cela sont
l'otage ne peut pas être technocratique
basé sur des tableaux de bord de suivi
d'indicateurs multi tons qu'il faudrait
rendre compte en continu ce qu'il
devient parfois pour le moment dans la
réalité du terrain
c'est comme si pour faire classe on
passait son temps à remplir les tableaux
de bord à double entrée on enseigne e
plus et ses dimensions et quand même
enfin après à prendre en compte
le directeur d'école de la même façon
avec l'animation et la coordination des
équipes et il a le risque de se couper
des préoccupations professionnelles d d
d enseignants professionnels et concrète
s'il rentre uniquement dans une logique
de gestion et du coup ils s'éloignent du
coeur du métier et le coeur du métier si
on veut faire réussir ses élèves qui ont
du mal à réussir et dont on mesure
difficultés en particulier les enquêtes
internationales c'est l'acte pédagogique
c'est la qualité de cet acte qu'il faut
travailler qu'il faut mettre en avant
sans cesse alors le directeur d'école il
a besoin d'être déchargé jeudi tout à
l'heure de certaines tâches
administratives parce qu'il ya un
empilement c'est clair nous on demande
la création d'un métier de secrétariat
il a besoin de temps pour se recentrer
sur des démissions qui dynamise vraiment
l'école qui dynamisent l'activité de
l'école autour du projet d'école il doit
rester en lien avec les élèves et on
peut imaginer par exemple qu' il soit le
maître surnuméraires dans l'école vous
savez que c'est une une revendication
comporte depuis longtemps à m de plus
que deux classes qui a fait l'objet
aussi gelé rappelé tout à l'heure d'une
expérimentation qui prend en charge des
élèves à certains moments de la journée
et qui participe à l'élaboration de
projets ou organisent des activités
éducatives
cela pourrait prendre forme par une raie
de redéfinition de son temps de service
une part en direction de l'enseignement
en tant que maîtres surnuméraires et une
part affectée à l'accomplissement de ces
de ses missions ensuite deuxième
question qui était posée c'était à
propos des obligations de service des
enseignants est ce qu elles sont
adaptées à l'école d'aujourd'hui nous
plus plus que jamais on se dit que de
nouvelles modalités du travail
d'organisation des enseignants sont
nécessaires le métier il est soumis à
des tensions du fait des nouvelles
mesures
depuis la rentrée 2007 elles elles sont
nombreuses
nouvelle semaine scolaire passage à 24
heures hebdomadaires avec de nouveaux
programmes alourdi un qui alourdissent
le
le travail des enseignants mise en place
de l'aide personnalisée
alors même que les cadres d'exercice du
métier se dégrade avec là aussi un
alourdissement de la charge de travail
concentré sur un temps réduit les 48
heures annuelles que les collègues on a
assuré pour les animations pédagogiques
le travail en équipe les réunions de
parents le suivi des projets personnels
de scolarisation pour les enfants en
situation de handicap c'est pas une
mince affaire c'est un gros travail et
les conseils d'école ne suffisent pas
notamment et l'opération et la
conception de projets pédagogiques pour
nous tant de travail enseignant et temps
scolaire des élèves doivent être
dissociée déconnecté dans le cadre d'une
diminution du temps d'enseignement sans
réduction du temps d'apprentissage pour
les élèves
alors on ouvre on le voit couplée avec
la demande de maîtres surnuméraires qui
permettrait de sortir d'un exercice trop
solitaire dudu du métier et de de la
logique à mettre une classe en mettant
en place d'autres fonctionnement dans
l'école pour répondre aux besoins des
élèves et en particulier des élèves
prioritaires c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont
en difficulté
ça permettra aussi de croiser les
regards ça donnerait aussi cette ce mode
de fonctionnement des marges de
manoeuvre aux équipes d'écoles pour
organiser sur le temps de classe du
travail en petits groupes
parce qu'on le voit bien les élèves en
difficulté ils ont besoin de ce cadre de
travail en petits groupes de tout le
monde s'accorde à dire que la difficulté
scolaire
elle est là elle à être prises sur le
temps de d'enseignement est sûr sûr sûr
sûr sûr le temps de classe déconnecté
s'étant devrait aussi permettre de
libérer plus de temps pour le travail en
équipe notamment et le temps pour
l'équipe ne peut avoir du sens que dans
des démarches pédagogiques qui dépasse
la structure de classe
il faut en effet du temps pour la
définition des besoins des élèves sur un
groupe d'âge par exemple un cycle et
l'analyse de l'évolution au fil de
l'année et aussi du temps pour
l'organisation du décloisonnement et la
constitution de groupes de besoins sur
sur un cycle
voilà un peu donc notre notre notre idée
sur le temps et je reprends pour
conclure l'idée de dissocier de
déconnecter le temps de travail
enseignant et le temps de scolaire des
élèves
le chef d'établissement doit-il être un
pilote un gestionnaire coordinateur il
pourrait tentant de répondre à cette
question en affirmant que le chef
d'établissement
comme tout cadre du système éducatif
doit être poli compétents et donc qu'il
est nécessaire qu'il soit à la fois
pilote gestionnaire et coordonnateur il
semble cependant que dans la dynamique
attendue d'une amélioration de la
gestion des ressources humaines dans les
établissements l'image du pilote soit
plus pertinente
en effet elle renvoie une fonction
amener ses passagers vers une
destination qui induit une
responsabilité
mieux vaut ne pas perdre trop de
passagers en route et suppose une
expertise certains chemins sont sans
doute plus sûres que les autres si ces
éléments sont bien reconnues dans le
second degré que ce soit dans la voie
générale et technologique ou dans la
voie professionnelle les choses sont
plus complexes au niveau de l'école
primaire
les textes sont prolixes pour fixer les
responsabilités du directeur mais ils
deviennent étrangement muet pour fixer
les moyens par lesquels ces charges
peuvent être exercés la mise en place
des réseaux ambition réussite nous
apporte quelques enseignements cette
affaire dans le dispositif initialement
imaginée à l'élaboration duquel notre
syndicat avait été associé les chefs
d'établissements étaient associés les
chefs d'établissement donc dû des écoles
les chats les émissions du second degré
et les directeurs des écoles du secteur
devait être associés pour constituer un
comité directeur du réseau porter le nom
de comité exécutif ce qui n'était
peut-être pas le plus habile l'hymen de
la circonscription devait pour sa part
être associés aux hypers pour constituer
un pôle externe d'évaluation et
d'accompagnement du dispositif
cette organisation présente l avantage
de donner aux directeurs des écoles une
reconnaissance statutaire fonctionnel et
permettait en outre d'envisager une
meilleure continuité entre avec les
évaluations entre le premier et le
second degré
malheureusement
de fortes pressions ont conduit à une
révision de ce dispositif et ont
débouché sur l'implication de l'hygiène
dans le comité de direction est sur la
suppression du pôle évaluatif envisagée
cet exemple montre bien les réticences
et les résistances au changement qui
rendent souvent difficile la mise en
oeuvre d' évolution significative
il faut pourtant reconnaître que les
modalités organisationnelles sont
déterminantes pour l'efficacité du
pilotage à cet égard le nouveau
dispositif associant des établissements
du premier et du second degré dans une
dynamique visant à structurer l'offre
éducative en référence au socle commun
des connaissances et des compétences tel
qu'il est mis en place par exemple dans
certains établissements de l'académie de
rennes nous semble constituer un axe de
réflexion tout à fait pertinent son
développement nécessiterait cependant
que soit sérieusement remis en cause des
éléments structurants du système
scolaire que la notion de responsabilité
fonctionnelle
celle-ci ne suppose pas nécessairement
l'instauration d'un échelon hiérarchique
de proximité supplémentaires dans le
premier degré mais doit donner aux
directeurs la capacité et les moyens de
fixer des orientations en mobilisant
l'équipe pédagogique
c'est bien dans une logique de
responsabilité partagée et dans une
complémentarité des regards que doit
être conçu le pilotage et non dans une
concurrence totalement contreproductive
dans cette logique il est légitime que
les chefs d'établissements du second
degré et les directeurs d'école assume
le pilotage des actions éducatives mis
en place tandis que les corps
d'inspection pourrait concentrer leurs
énergies sur l'évaluation et la
recherche de cohérence des pratiques à
l'échelle d'un territoire défini sur la
base du procès d'un projet éducatif
partager une telle approche suppose
toutefois une porosité des structures
qui est loin d'être fréquentent ce jour
même si chacun se lamente sur la trop
grande rupture entre premier et second
degrés et c'est un pas catastrophiques
sur les élèves et tout particulièrement
bien sûr sur les plus fragiles d'entre
eux les obligations de service des
enseignants sont elles adaptées à
l'école aujourd'hui s'il appartient
légitimement aux organisations
syndicales représentatives des
personnels de s'exprimer sur ce point
notre organisation tient cependant à
soumettre une réflexion la notion
d'obligation de service porte certes en
elle une logique indispensables visant à
fixer les contraintes mais surtout
les marges de responsabilité et d'action
des principaux acteurs de l'acte
éducatif toute l'administration et la
gestion du système scolaire ne peuvent
en effet prendre sens que dans l'aide
susceptible d'être apportée aux
enseignants pour que ceux ci fassent
preuve de la plus de la meilleure
efficacité possible au service des
élèves dès lors l'idée d'obligations de
service ne doit pas nécessairement être
lue comme une contrainte mais plutôt
s'inscrire dans une forme de contrat de
confiance entre la nation et ses
enseignants selon nous la seule
obligation est en véritablement du sens
et celle de la mobilisation de tous les
moyens et toutes les énergies en vue de
la réussite de tous les élèves
à la question posée je ferai pas preuve
de beaucoup d'originalité en disant que
finalement c'est un peu les tours à la
fois mais en sachant que sur chacun des
paramètres les marges sont extrêmement
limités pilote sous un pilote
automatique puisque de fait les moyens
qui sont attribués aux établissements ne
lui offre pas finalement
plusieurs parcours possible et de ce
point de vue là s'il ya 2,1 points
atteints il ya plusieurs voies possibles
pour y arriver
et de fait en d'autres temps
l'établissement de moyens qui sont
quasiment adapté aux structures la marge
de manoeuvre est le choix des parcours
les plus intéressants qui sont pas
forcément la ligne droite sont
effectivement très très limité de ce
point de vue là un gestionnaire sans
aucun doute mais il ya aussi un
intendant établissements scolaires et de
ce point de vue là la dimension gestion
même si elle tend à se développer je
tairai n'est pas ce qui fait l'identité
propre de chaque établissement
un coordonnateur effectivement
idéalement ça devrait être cette
fonction-là qui devrait primer et dans
le cas d'une autorité hiérarchique
aujourd'hui qui attend sans qui tend à
se renforcer on a plus souvent
l'impression d'avoir un manager et je
pense que ce point de vue à la formation
à l'école supérieure de l'éducation
nationale donc les scènes qui est à
poitiers en attendant justement à
développer ce point là que la partie
pédagogie est quand même le coeur de
notre métier nos pratiques et les chefs
d'établissement sont d'anciens
enseignants pour la plupart de ce point
de vue là cette dimension pédagogique
tend à disparaître
ut ray avec la avec la fonction de chef
d'établissement et le conseil
pédagogique de ce point de vue là n'est
pas venu corriger ce qui nous paraît un
manque et en présidant le conseil
pédagogique je pense que la fonction
hiérarchique tendance imprimée sur la
démarche de coordonnateur on aimerait
que ce soit en conclusion un
facilitateur
mais pour que ce soit un facilitateur
encore faudrait-il qu'ils aient les
moyens de pouvoir mettre de l'huile dans
les rouages
et de ce point de vue là je trouve qu'il
n'a pas suffisamment à la possibilité de
je dirais donné une ses moyens
nécessaires pour permettre à l'ensemble
des équipes de fonctionner je t'ai rien
un discours et des pratiques qui sortent
des moyens on dit toujours un peu de
manière tu as comme explication qui
vaudrait pour toute situation mais en
pole cas particuliers 7 devient
particulièrement vrai dans les dernières
années en cours et on voit les l'éveil
des conseils d'administration de rester
dans les établissements scolaires qui
montre que le chef d'agissements et
souvent aussi bien seul dans ces
situations là donc métier difficile s'il
en est
c'est par exemple là encore on est dans
le modèle français lorsqu'on parle de
chefs d'établissement c'est une de nos
spécificités
on a parfois chercher excessivement des
modèles ailleurs que dans la tradition
française
on aurait pu voir je crois dans certains
pays comme l'espagne me semble-t-il
le chef d'établissement est
impersonnelle élus parmi ses pairs et
moushin terreau paraissent en quelque
sorte pour un temps limité il n'est pas
il n'est pas nommé il n'est pas désignée
comme telle mais on est effectivement
dans un modèle français auquel nous
tenons à dire que avant tout le chef
d'établissement ses deux représentants
de l'état
c'est c'est le garant effectivement du
respect des décisions prises par la
collectivité nationale en termes
d'éducation et l'application des
programmes et des règles de
fonctionnement dans son établissement
à ce titre et ça nous permet de faire le
lien avec la question précédente
il nous semble qu'effectivement il faut
un chef entre guillemets dans tous les
établissements scolaires et vous savez
chaque sénateur rapporteur que le
syndicat du primaire qui nous est
associé est tout à fait attaché à la
notion de statut pour les directeurs
d'école et je fais parle par cette
parenthèse le rappel de cette position
alors bien évidemment il faut qu' il
reste lié profondément à au corps
professoral qui fait l'essentiel de du
fonctionnement des établissements
pour nous il est essentiel effectivement
que les chefs d'établissement soient ils
le sont pour beaucoup il a été dit issus
des corps professoraux parce que
assumant d'autres fonctions
d'organisation de gestion bien
évidemment il reste empreint de cette
fonction essentielle pour nous le centre
du système éducatif c'est la classe m et
ses élèves
et finalement tout ce qui est autour
doit servir ce qui se passe à ce centre
c'est à dire le lieu où ce feu et se
transmet la capacité d'apprentissage se
transmet se transmettre les savoirs
était alors en ce sens effectivement oui
un peu un chef d'établissement vu comme
un facilitateur de fonctionnement
vu comme un serviteur je vais dire comme
un ministre puisque vous savez que des
teams logiquement ça veut dire
strictement la même chose
un ministre c'est celui qui est
serviteur des autres bon je crois que
c'est un petit peu sale la façon dont
nous envoyons à la représentation
alors revenons à la question des pauses
et sur les obligations de service des
enseignants
la question serait tenté de poser ses
sont ils aujourd'hui dans la possibilité
d'en assumer d'autres
un enseignant conçoit réalise ses cours
les donne on vérifie l'assimilation
l'apprentissage vérifie le travail
assure le suivi et l'orientation de ses
élèves participent aux organismes aux
instances statutaires des établissements
il est souvent élus dans son
établissement
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup et si on
se fonde sur les définitions qui sont
encore celles réglementaire la seule
réalité des cours assure 36 heures de
travail hebdomadaires alors si l'on veut
que d'autres obligations rentrer dans
cette fonction
il faudra donc envisager qu'ils
enseignent - mais qu'est-ce qu'un
enseignant qui enseigna moins ça ne
serait plus un enseignant dans ce cas là
on devrait dans toute légitimité
s'interroger sur l'évolution du type
d'adultes humain ni en rapport
d'accompagnement plutôt que frontale
avec des adolescents et avec des jeunes
gens et les jeunes filles on change de
monde on change d'univers
on sait que c'est un petit peu vers cela
que souvent vous voudrez tendre il est
évident que ce n'est pas du tout notre
point de vue nous croyons au contraire
que notre pays a besoin d'enseigner a
besoin de donner des savoirs
divers et importants et que pour cela il
faut que les personnels enseignants se
dédie à la fonction enseignante
une fois encore dans le cadre même de ce
qu'en temps de travail en une semaine
cela représente
nous voyons guère quel autre obligation
on pourrait alors demander
merci chez d'établissement et pour nous
c'est plutôt l'équipe de direction donc
qui doit être un peu tout cela
elle ne doit impulser en projet être un
facilitateur d'innovation comme vous
l'avez dit un appui aussi elle doit être
à l'écouté ouverte au dialogue et
reconnaître la place de chacun l'équipe
de direction de ça va entraîner et
déléguée elle est à la fois le porteur
d'un projet et puis aussi elle
représente l'état et il faut que ces
deux aspects de la fonction comme je
l'avais dit précédemment ne conduise pas
à des situations impossibles
c'est à dire vouloir la réussite des
élèves d'un côté et puis de l'autre être
obligé de se rendre de rendre les moyens
nécessaires pour ce qui est du premier
degré et bien nous sommes pour
l'évolution aussi de l'école et là nous
vous donnerons des documents nous avons
produit un quatre pages à ce sujet les
obligations de service des enseignants
sont elles adaptées à l'école
d'aujourd'hui
eh bien je crois qu'on a vite passé à la
trappe le travail de la commission
pochard le livre vert qu'il faudrait
peut-être utilement relire pour nous il
faut penser l'ensemble du travail des
enseignants et pas seulement les
obligations statutaires il est bien
certain que 15h 18h ce n'est pas à cela
que se réduit le travail du professeur
il a après il faut prendre en compte
dans toutes les tâches dans le métier et
pas seulement leur du coup leur passion
les évaluations mais aussi l'aide
individualisée et personnalisée qui doit
être au coeur du métier et non à la
périphérie
donc ce ne doit pas être payés en heures
supplémentaires mais ça doit être
intégré dans le service commettant une
mission
importante contrairement aux collègues
on pense que on sait oui comme lui on
pense que le monde change et qu'il faut
que le métier suivent cette évolution
pour rendre service aux élèves parce que
c'est bien là aussi un service nous
sommes fonctionnaires au service du
public pour ce qui est des deux degrés
le premier le second il ne faut pas
seconde à reese est le premier degré et
prix maryse et le second il faut qu'on
pense à une école initial qui a ses
objectifs propres et une école moyenne
qui a aussi ses objectifs propres
avec l'acquisition et la validation en
fin de scolarité obligatoire du socle
commun
donc c'est un continuum éducatif à
réaliser et certainement qu'un travail
en réseau proxi un échange entre les
deux les deux degrés peut être
intéressant et ne pas cumuler les
inconvénients du second degré et du
premier degré c'est-à-dire bien intégrer
la dimension pédagogique dans le second
degré et ne pas cumuler les défauts des
des deux autres décrets passer la parole
au fatah la première question donc le
chef d'établissement soient pilotes
certainement mais utilisant un second et
des instruments précis de navigation et
des conseillers en effet le chef
d'établissement peut connaître ces
personnels s'ils étaient vraiment formés
à la grh pas toujours le cas et en
partie à la gestion c'est assez peu
souvent le code kaman
mais il reste la pédagogie et
l'enseignement des disciplines pour
lesquelles le chef d'établissement n'est
pas toujours le mieux placé de par sa
formation antérieure
je voudrais faire une petite allusion au
rapport grosperrin qui a qualifié
l'histoire géographie éducation civique
et les svt de matière et non pas
dissipées dicter ce qui relève pour
l'histoire de
la nana chaix du chemin de fer disparu
ya longtemps et du calendrier des postes
oberthur pour la géographie ce qui est
quand même une vision extrêmement
passéiste de ces disciplines qui reflète
parfois ce que malheureusement monsieur
tournier ne m'en voudra pas à certain
nombre de chefs d'établissement qui sont
plus toujours très au courant et c'est
bien normal moi je ne rejette pas du
tout la pierre ne connaissent pas des
disciplines scientifiques des
disciplines littéraires des disciplines
ont dit les deux je pense que là il ya
une aide nécessaire c'est pour cela que
nous existons à gestionnaire certes un
peu il doit être aidé par des
spécialistes qui sont capables eux aussi
d'expliquer leur choix est là j'assiste
pour demain je pense que les
gestionnaires devraient être capables
d'expliquer les choix qu'ils prennent
pour orienter les établissements
scolaires je pense qu'en tant aussi
parents d'élèves ou haas ancien membre
d'une association de parents d'élèves
que les gestionnaires ont beaucoup à
faire dans ce domaine pour faire
comprendre les choix financiers qui sont
les leurs même contrat un coordonnateur
oui si les moyens lui sont donnés pour
se faire entendre de tous et ensuite de
retransmettre à tous les aides
extérieures au pilotage et à la
coordination sont essentielles et par
exemple des audits de plusieurs types
devrait être mené pour approcher les
méthodes de gestion de grh et surtout de
pédagogie engagés seuls à regard
extérieur est susceptible de donner une
vision nombre et non biaisée aux chefs
d'établissement l'inspection dans ce
domaine un rôle fondamental à jouer avec
les chefs d'établissements et ya
nécessairement des formations acquérir
préalablement dans le cadre d'une
responsabilité partagée
je pense que là ça fait appel à une
formation collective ou inspecteur chef
d'établissement et a71 nombre de
personnels devraient travailler ensemble
être formés ensemble pour avoir un
objectif commun ce n'est pas toujours le
cas actuellement
enfin pour les obligations de service
des enseignants c'est une question
difficile
les textes de 1997 devrait largement
suffire
les enseignants remplissant actuellement
toutes les tâches qui leur sont confiées
devrait pouvoir faire tout ce qui leur
est demandé
toutefois depuis quelques années et face
à une demande sociale de plus en plus
vives
les demandes d'actions pour les
enseignants se multiplient au détriment
parfois de ce qui était considéré il ya
peu de temps encore comme et sciences
elle est sans contestation possible
la transmission pur des savoirs de type
universitaire face à ce dilemme
croissant augmenter le temps de présence
d'enseignants demanderai de nombreux
aménagements et des coûts en
augmentation
aura-t-on de meilleurs résultats
scolaires pour cela rien ne permet de
l'affirmer il faudrait certainement se
pencher sur des méthodes et démarches
pédagogiques plus en conformité avec des
lieux de réussite et de résultats
d'expérimentations conforme à la
première question posée lors de
l'ouverture de cette séance les élèves
apprennent qu'ils mieux lorsque les
enseignants sont plus présents et plus
longtemps dans les écoles et dans les
lycées dans les collèges c'est une
question est talonné par des
expérimentations bien ciblé d'abord et
nous n'avons toujours pas la réponse
sur les deux questions qui sont posées
la première sur le chef d'établissement
doit-il être un pilote un gestionnaire
un coordonnateur c'est vrai que si on y
réfléchit pas plus on aurait tendance à
dire comme l'on dit beaucoup de mes
collègues un peu les 3 après il faut
savoir ce qu'on met derrière les mots
nous on y réfléchissant un petit peu
plus alors je rappelle qu'en plus cette
question il était posée dans le cas de
la gestion des ressources humaines
bref donc ça le connaught quand même la
question dans l'incertain un sens et du
coup nous ont dit est-ce qu'il doit être
un pilote du coup pas vraiment parce que
un chef d'établissement
le pilote se dire qu'il choisit la
direction qu'il va prendre or la
direction
c'est au niveau du contenu c'est les
programmes c c'est oui c'est
essentiellement les programmes et la
définition des diplômes et puis après
pour tout ce qui est des choix interne
de mise en oeuvre
nous on considère qu'il agit par
délégation du conseil d'administration
et que l'instance de qui définit la
direction et les orientations choisies
c'est le conseil d'administration après
skis les gestionnaires comme on parle
des ressources humaines où on dit non
parce que les ressources elles sont
attribuées par l'état et les statuts des
personnels existe et donc le chef
d'établissement qui est quand même
représentant de l'état est garant du
respect des lois et règlements ne peut
faire que les mettre en oeuvre et du
coup nous on considère qu'il est plutôt
le troisième c'est à dire qu'il est
coordonnateur on lui donne des moyens on
devrait lui donner des moyens parce
qu'il faut déconnecter cette question-là
d'effectifs rendent la question
récurrente de l'absence de moyens mais
dans un système qui fonctionne on doit
lui donner les moyens correspondant à la
politique qui était chargé de mettre en
oeuvre ce sont en grande partie des
moyens humains et il doit coordonner cet
ensemble pour les mettre en adéquation
avec les programmes et avec les
formations à mettre en oeuvre et d'autre
part avec les délibérations du conseil
d'administration et j'y reviens parce
que c'était ma conclusion il fait
j'avais noté la conclusion de cette
partie là c'est que en conséquence il
devait être président du conseil
d'adminstration jeu j'ouvre une toute
petite parenthèse sur le cas particulier
de l'enseignement agricole où il ya une
deuxième chose qui n'est pas normal une
exception qui n'est pas normal
concernant
les personnels de direction c'est qu'ils
ne sont pas dans un statut de corps
comme à l'éducation nationale mais sur
un statut d'emploi qui pose des
problèmes de carrière et un certain
nombre de difficultés on souhaiterait y
remédier sur la deuxième question sur
les obligations de service des
enseignants sont elles adaptées à
l'école d'aujourd'hui et je rajoute du
coup devrait évoluer nous ont dit elles
ne sont plus adaptées elle devrait
évoluer la première est simple raison
c'est que c'est quand même la seule
catégorie de salariés dans ce pays qui
depuis la fin de la guerre la deuxième
guerre n'a pas vu son temps de travail
diminuer et contrairement à ce que
disait le collègue tout à l'heure 18h ne
correspondent pas à 36 heures une
enquête de l'éducation nationale à
l'époque où luc ferry était était
ministre de l'éducation nationale avait
conclu que le temps réel de travail des
enseignants était de 42 heures
je vous invite à ressortir ce rapport
donc pour ces raisons là nous ont dit
qu'elles doivent évoluer et qu'elles
doivent évoluer vers le sens d'une
diminution des obligations de service et
la deuxième chose qui a quand même
évolué c'est que le taux de
scolarisation notamment dans le second
degré a fortement évolué depuis un
certain nombre d'années ce qui a
augmenté quand même l'hétérogénéité des
classes et qui complexifie et qui
demande à ce qu'il y ait un suivi
individualisé des élèves beaucoup plus
poussée qu'il ne pouvait être à une
certaine époque
deuxième chose et là je reviens plus à
l'enseignement agricole on a développé
quelque chose qui est une des
spécificités positive de l'est de
l'enseignement agricole qui est la
pluridisciplinarité qui demande de
renforcer la concertation entre les
enseignants et tout ça ça demande du
temps donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous les évolutions que l'on souhaite
dans les obligations de service c'est
une diminution globale mais aussi
d'intégrer dans les obligations de
service mais en venant en déduction deux
heures de déduire deux heures des
obligations de service de façon à
laisser le temps pour la concertation
pour le suivi individualisé des élèves
et la coordination des équipes
pédagogiques
bien continuer première question sur le
chef d'établissement
la question est simple ça rend vos
fonctionnement des établissements et à
partir de là nous nous répondrons par
une chose qui est que le chef
d'établissement n'est pas un surhomme
ce n'est pas une personne seule et
isolée à la tête d'un établissement
si c'est ça la définition ça signifie
que vous êtes en train d'expliquer qu'
il y à un glissement sémantique qui va
se produire à ce que le chef
d'établissement devienne un chef
d'entreprise
la réponse est non le chef
d'établissement n'est pas un chef
d'entreprise il évolue dans un cadre
statutaire nationale et réglementaires
c'est à dire que la question est comment
chacun peut exercer sa mission selon son
statut dans le respect et la
reconnaissance de l'autre c'est le
respect de la reconnaissance des
missions de chacun qui fait que l'on
peut effectivement obéir un cadre
réglementaire ce qui signifie qu'à
partir de là il va qui ont très
rapidement de questions vous allez voir
la brutalité les volumes l'évaluation
mérite des personnels par
l'établissement
non le recrutement par les chefs
d'établissements des personnels non
à partir de là passons à des choses plus
importantes et plus intéressante
c'est à dire que les chefs
d'établissement un statut à de le
protéger mais on ne peut pas en faire
les boucs émissaires comme on a tenté de
le faire en s'amusant avec ce qu'ils
toucheraient sur les ombres la
performance arrêtons d essayer d'opposer
les personnels les uns aux autres
une communauté éducative c'est un
équilibre
le chef d'établissement a son rôle qui
est un rôle d'impulsion de d'une amie
prévu par ses cadres
les enseignants des obligations de
service oui ils ont des obligations de
service mais moi je vous renvoie à une
autre question est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'école c'est-à-dire la société
c'est-à-dire l'état respecte ses
enseignants je suis pas sûr que la
réponse vous agrée pour nous c'est non
puisque comment respecter aujourd'hui
des enseignants quand on les paye aussi
mal en fonction du niveau d'études qu'on
en demande notamment aujourd'hui la
mastérisation
à partir du moment où on a supprimé leur
formation c'est vrai que le métier
d'enseignant ne s'apprend pas
ils se déterminent sur le terrain alors
c'est très simple aujourd'hui vous avez
un avion alors pas de pas de vision vous
avez un avion 15 stagiaires y en a douze
comme un sac à dos 3 qui ont un sac de
pain prend un parachute comment vont-ils
atterrir vous imaginez qu'elle est
effectivement l'arrivée au sol des
différents stagiaires
c'est exactement ce que nous vivons ça
signifie à partir de là qu'on
s'interroge pas aussi sur la formation
continue des enseignants tout l'expert
pédagogique toute formation doit
effectivement être continué avec un
acronyme monsieur le sénateur qui
s'appelle le pass ça fait presque mal
c'est le plan académique de formation il
fait tellement mal qu'il n'existe plus à
partir de là tout ceci fait que la
logique du métier d'enseignant c'est
quoi c'est s'interroger comment jeu
rendant métier est-ce que je rentre
simplement sur une logique de niveau
universitaire si c'est cela c'est pas
forcément la réponse à nos missions
est-ce que l'entrée dans le métier ne
s'accompagne pas d'un accompagnement
d'une logique de formation mais aussi
d'une autre logique que je vous demande
d'intégrer quelque chose qui n'est pas
réussi pour l'instant comment on donne
la chance à des enseignants qui ne
veulent plus poursuivre le métier de
pouvoir effectivement se réorienter
c'est à dire la possibilité d'une autre
carrière d'une deuxième carrière
ce qui signifie que je viens très
rapidement la voie professionnelle et
aux statuts les plp parce que nous
sommes très attachés à notre statut nous
pensons nous sommes tous enseignants
mais en force en fonction de l'endroit
où lens n en fait pas le même métier plp
notre statut date de 2000 puisque nous
l'avons fait effectivement nous sommes
battus pour qu'il soit nouveau rénové il
a été modifié et dernière puisque nous
pouvons nous pouvons enseigne au bts
à partir de là ce statut 2010 croit il
dit protégé par la loi de 2005 sait plus
quel intéressante cette vague 2005 la
liberté pédagogique des enseignants elle
s'arrête font elles s'arrêtent
effectivement par rapport aux
contraintes du métier des obligations de
service qui sont le respect des
programmes le respect du cadre
statutaire nationale ce qui signifie
donc à partir de là le plp en
enseignement général et bivalent il est
bivalent il ya ce spécificités liées à
l'enseignement professionnel
il est tellement bivalent que les
recteurs aujourd'hui ont décrété par
exemple à l'académie de poitiers comme
enseignement professionnel
compte tenu des sections d'enseignement
général on pourrait avoir trente élèves
par classe dans l'année prochaine ce
sera sûrement 35 parce qu'effectivement
les moyens soit environ pourquoi ne pas
s'arrêter moi je vous propose de créer
des amphis nous ferons cours
effectivement de manière théorique de
voir des élèves qui sont les plus
sociaux culturellement défavorisée
là ce sont les bonnes questions sur les
obligations de service et non pas de
s'interroger pour savoir ce qu'ils
peuvent faire en plus moi ce que je
m'interroge c'est effectivement
aujourd'hui comment on redonne
l'émission est la mission du plb elle
est prévue par son statut puisqu'elle
est déjà liée au fait que le plp fait 18
heures devant élèves comme ça vous a été
rappelé effectivement l'enquète précises
en fonction du corps le nombre d'heures
que l'on fait et ce ne sont pas
forcément les agrégés qui font plus
d'heures à partir de là la l'émission
des pelles pays fait 18 heures par
semaine devant l ennemi chaque semaine
il fait pas forcément 18 heures puisque
nous gérons effectivement les périodes
de cours les périodes de formation en
entreprise dans l'éducation nationale
doit rester le maître mais aussi ce
qu'on appelle le ppip
le projet pluridisciplinaire à caractère
professionnel quel est ce monstre ce
monstre c'est effectivement comment je
fais vivre ensemble sur la pédagogie du
projet qui permet effectivement à des
élèves d'identifier de reconnaître et de
développer quoi ce que nous en faisons
c'est à dire des individus autonomes qui
vont pouvoir s'insérer dans la société
à partir de là c'est ça ses obligations
des enseignants font qu'un nous rend au
statut et font que le chef
d'établissement qui n'est pas un
surhomme de respecter ses missions parce
que s'il n'est pas seul on ne parle pas
des partenariats je ne parle pas des
corps d'inspection qui l'a aussi
faudrait largement les détacher d'un
certain nombre de missions
administratives pour les renvoyer
véritablement plus longtemps sur l'autre
terrain pour l'accompagnement des
enseignants et notamment pour
l'enseignante des enseignants en
difficulté dont vous voyez que par
rapport à cette logique que vous posez
vous ne posez pas simplement la question
du métier d'enseignant vous poser
aujourd'hui la question qui est qu'elle
est la pression de l'opinion publique
sur l'école est ce que l'on veut que
l'école soit ouverte 24 heures sur 24
afin que les parents déposent le matin
lors gosses à l'école et que le soir là
le rendant produits semi finis
si c'est cette réponse nous avons
effectivement nos limites
beaucoup de choses ont été dites je vais
faire court je sur la première question
je voudrais juste interrogé sur le le
mot pilotage un qui fait florès dans le
monde de l'éducation depuis un certain
temps il a été apportée de la gestion
des entreprises privées et on voit
qu'ils les ont l'accord port sont jamais
l'interroger a le mot pilotes et
employés sans cesse il est généralement
associé aux notions de tableaux de bord
et d'indicateurs qui ont une certaine
validité lorsqu'il s'agit d'exécuter et
de suivre des budgets mais qui lorsqu'il
s'agit ses tableaux de bord de suivi des
performances scolaires liés à la
construction de savoir et à la
construction de compétences d'un d'homme
et de citoyen en devenir
parce que c'est ça le rôle fondamental
des établissements scolaires c'est de
faire en sorte d'accueillir des enfants
et les adolescents pour en faire des
citoyens et des hommes qui pensent
qu'une culture c'est ça avant tout s'est
passé ça qu'il ne faut pas oublier donc
la notion de tableaux de bord et
d'indicateurs sur ces points-là
particulier à beaucoup de limites alors
sinon pour savoir d'abord qui doit
piloter il s'agit d'en identifier
de quoi l'objet de l'objet du pilotage
d'une part et d'autre part laisse le
sens la direction dans lequel on doit le
faire sinon dans un sens plus comme un
bon s'il faut l'adopter ce mot pilotes
ont l'adoptera on peut dire
qu'effectivement chez l'établissement
rempli les trois missions qui sont
décrites dans la question numéro 1 à cet
égard nous regrettons que les corps
d'inspection n'est pas été enfin ne
seront pas compris dans les ressources
humaines de la question
on est oubliés deuxièmement les
obligations de service des enseignants
là aussi je ferai très court puisque je
laisserai les organisations syndicales
qui indiquent les enseignants y répondre
alors nous on pense qu un meilleur
fonctionnement des établissements
résoudre sans doute dans la capacité
collective des acteurs des
établissements à travailler ensemble à
donner du sens à leur engagement
éducatif à s'impliquer dans des
démarches innovantes à construire leur
lieu de travail comme un centre
d'initiative pour transformer l'école
faire évoluer leurs pratiques former des
équipes de coordinateur de filières de
domaine de discipline des équipes de
porteurs de projet reconnue
ceci nécessite à ce que soit incorporé
du temps de concertation à l'actuel
temps de service nous laisserons à nos
collègues donc les plus concernés
s'exprime largement sur ce sujet cet
égard je vais faire simplement une
dernière remarque pour conclure un
rapport récent édictées par les éditer
par les services du premier ministre ont
font apparaître que la france est un des
pays de l' ocde qui possède le taux
d'encadrement le plus bas bien sûr les
deux sujets alors sur les chefs
d'établissement et représentant de
l'unsa du snpden et du siennes sont
exprimés je rajouterais juste un élément
pour nous les chefs d'établissement ne
peuvent en aucune façon être des
recruteurs c'est considérons que ce
n'est pas aux chefs d'établissement à
recruter que là pour le coup si nous
rentrons dans cette logique de rentrer
dans une logique qui renvoie à
l'autonomie et à la concurrence entre
établissements et cette logique nous ne
voulons pas y rentrer au niveau du
se-unsa
pour en venir au service des enseignants
je crois qu'il faut être au clair sur ce
que l'on entend par service aux
enseignants il ya le service et
statutaire il ya le travail des
enseignants le travail des enseignants
va bien au delà du service statutaire je
prends pas un peu cas des certifier que
sont les 18 heures par exemple il ya
toute la charge de travail de
préparation de suivi de recherche etc
mais enfin ça va même au delà il ya les
heures supplémentaires il ya les
activités de principal il ya les
rencontres avec les parents etc etc
je le dis parce que je ne voudrais pas
que l'on réduise l'activité des
enseignants à la seule activité
statutaire
dès 18h pour les certifiés des 24 plus
trois pour les professeurs des écoles
par exemple
la charge de travail des enseignants
elle est réelle elle est lourde elle est
de plus en plus lourdes
parce que là aussi ils sont confrontés à
ce qu'est la société avec ses
difficultés ses faiblesses et parfois sa
violence je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
donc sur cette question du service je
pense que enfin on peut pas concentrer
le débat sur la question du service des
enseignants ceci étant que les choses
évoluent sans doute là aussi le monde a
évolué il ya des missions nouvelles qui
apparaissent il ya des il ya des
missions nouvelles qui apparaissent
j'observe d'ailleurs que dans le premier
degré alors avec tout le mal qu'on peut
en penser 60 d'aspe sur la réforme
darcos
on a revu les obligations de service des
enseignants puisque le bigard fin le
contenu d'obligations de service
enseignant qui était à 27 eur c'était 27
non c'était c'était 26 plus une on est
passé à 24 +3 et on a intégré dans les
obligations de service des enseignants
du temps de concertation
l'aide personnalisée alors sous des
formes qu'il faut mais je ne le
justifient pas mais mais on le on a
modifié des choses donc je pense que sur
cet aspect là il faut être attentif à
deux choses les obligations de service
peuvent apparaître comme un frein mais
n'oubliez pas que c'est une protection
c'est une protection pour les
enseignants aimons tant que responsable
syndical et secrétaire général d'une
organisation syndicale d'enseignants
je souhaite je souhaite que les
enseignants soient protégés alors je le
dis parce que là encore ça renvoie
d'ailleurs en débat que nous avons eu
tout à l'heure sur les recteurs et les
rectorats aujourd'hui l'inventivité à la
manoeuvre
c'est à dire que heureusement encore que
nous avons un statut qui nous protège
parce que et les secrétaires généraux et
les grh les drh dans l'est dans l'est
dans les rectorats ne respecte à kalemie
où il intègra qu'aligner les recteurs ne
manquent pas d'imagination
là encore pour contourner la loi et
faire faire aux enseignants plus que ne
le précisent leurs obligations
statutaires
bon donc je dis pas qu'il faut être figé
mais qu'on entend dans discours mais
enfin quand même
otg les salariés c'est quand même me
semble-t-il là aussi un élément
important et sur lequel d'ailleurs
l'état doit être exemplaire
bon donc pour résumer il y a des marges
de manoeuvre on peut discuter
là aussi on peut discuter si à des
contreparties 1,6 et travailler plus
pour gagner moins
ce qui est le cas quand même hein en
tout cas pour gagner autant mais même
moi parce qu'avec l'inflation etc
fais pas le dessin et la nouvelle loi
sur les retraites nous gagnons moins ça
marchera pas c'est à dire que dans le
cadre de discussions que l'on peut avoir
sur ces questions là c'est du gagnant
gagnant pour utiliser un terme que
certains utilisent souvent pas un peu
moins d'ailleurs depuis quelques temps
et rappelons nous qu on n'est pas dans
une négociation entre nonu joe on vous
écoute on écoute vos propos on écoute
vos positions ça fait parfait dans une
négociation on est bien d'accord mais ça
fait partie des éléments du paysage qui
ne faut pas négliger un binôme et vous
avez pas dépasser la ligne wuala mais
c'était juste
bon je vais essayer de faire vite parce
que beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites
la question à propos des chefs
d'établissement j'ai pas envie de
m'enfermer dans ce choix entre trois
termes finalement je crois que la
question qui veut être posée je suis pas
pourquoi elle et pas posé comme ça c'est
quel doit être le rôle du chef
d'établissement n'entame pédagogique en
termes de gestion des personnels donc en
tout cas c'est comme c'est à cette
question là que je me sens capable de
répondre plus qu'à mettre des croix en
phase de pilote gestionnaire au
coordonnateur mais de voir quels sont
les contours de son rôle de ce qu'il est
de ce qu'il devrait être
donc pour nous au delà de ces trois
termes le chef d'établissement doit être
avant tout celui qui anime et qui
coordonne qui organise le travail d'une
équipe sa ligne de conduite si on veut
continuer à user de la métaphore
productrice devons être cela mise en
oeuvre des politiques fixés au plan
national et les décisions prises par son
conseil d'administration c'est à dire
c'est ses deux casquettes un sa
casquette représentants de l'état et sa
casquette exécutif du conseil
d'administration
il n'a pas pour nous compétences pour
évaluer la pédagogie des enseignants et
à ce sujet donc là j'en viens un peu
plus sur la question de gestion des
personnels
on veut faire jouer au chef
d'établissement un rôle qui nous pose
problème pour le faire intervenir au
plus près de la gestion des ressources
humaines se pose la question de
l'évaluation individuelle qu'on veut
faire porter
aux chefs d'établissement seul alors
c'est vrai que ce qui se passe dans la
classe c'est un élément décisif est
essentiel de notre métier mais il n'est
pas le seul ne s'est pas le seul élément
de l'activité des enseignements de
second degré et comment un chef
d'établissement qui n'est pas compétent
dans le champ disciplinaire d'un
enseignant peut-il intervenir sur les
contenus discipline est enseignée dans
la classe ou sur les éléments
didactiques de la discipline
ces éléments étant étroitement en lien
avec le contenu enseigner donc on estime
qu'il n'a pas la légitimité à ça et on
est très attaché à la double évaluation
qui existe actuellement et ce point est
à l'origine de tensions fortes dans
cette dans les établissements du second
degré donc pour en finir avec le rôle du
chef d'établissement
je reprendrai très rapidement ce qui a
été dit à l'instant sur il n'est pas
question pour nous que le chef
d'établissement et un rôle de
recrutement des personnels en glisse de
plus en plus vers des missions d une
évolution du rôle des chefs
d'habillement vers un modèle qui est
celui effectivement de la gestion de
l'entreprise on est un peu fasciné par
ce modem les chefs d'établissement en
depuis quelques années la responsabilité
de recruter un certain nombre de
personnels
on veut maintenant leur faire recruter
les personnels enseignants dans les
établissements clair ils interviennent
dans les promotions
la démarche est toujours la même on
renforce la hiérarchie locale dans
l'évaluation individuelle et ça c'est
pas de nature à notre avis à améliorer
les performances du système c'est la
même logique de concurrence que celle
qu'on a décrite précédemment dans
l'autonomie sur les obligations de
service des enseignants je serai très
vite de pratiquement tout a été dit par
mes collègues de la fsu et du est celui
ça donc effectivement le
temps de travail d'un enseignant c'est
pas son maxima de service mais il faut
quand même noter que c'est comme c'est
le maxima de service qui définit
aujourd'hui statutairement les
obligations mais enfin une partie des
obligations de service des enseignants
et que ce sont effectivement les mêmes
depuis cinquante ans alors que le métier
a considérablement évolué et que des
métiers sont plus complexes
l'alourdissement de la charge de travail
est lié à plein de phénomènes on a plus
de classe en charge parce que les
horaires ont diminué par par discipline
en un public scolaire de plus en plus
divers c'est en social de plus en plus
forte
le développement des nouvelles
technologies une demande
d'individualisation de plus en plus
forte
aucun aménagement du temps de travail
est intervenu pour les personnels
d'éducation depuis depuis 50 ans donc
effectivement il est grand temps de
prendre en compte les évolutions de ce
métier du métier d'enseignant mais je
dirais aussi des autres personnels qui
sont oubliés comme ça a été soulignée
mais on ne parle pas des cpe des cop si
des agents des personnels de santé qui
sont tous des preuves source humaine
aussi d'établissement et donc il est
grand temps de prendre ça en compte et
je voudrais juste donc par une réduction
des maxima de service qui est puis des
heures des heures de concertation qui
sont intégrées dans le temps de service
les heures de prise en charge des
d'individualiser qui sont prises en
temps de service je voudrais juste
ajouter un dernier point c'est que dans
la question
qui est posé on sent un peu en creux on
a un peu l'impression qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'adaptation aux ça a été dit je crois
par l'un d'entre nous avant moi c'est
bien parce que la profession a su
adapter ses pratiques a su adapter ses
pratiques professionnelles notamment que
le nombre de bacheliers par exemple est
passé en 25 ans d'à peu près 20 % d'une
classe d'âge à plus de 60%
ce n'est pas que le fait il ya eu
forcément une adaptation de la
profession pour pour pour cette
évolution là et donc ça ça a été aussi
au prix d'une charge de travail toujours
plus grande et donc il faut adapter les
temps difficiles temps de travail pour
répondre aux exigences des personnels
pour mieux travailler bien mais bon je
vous entends bien mais je joue petite
difficulté c'est que je vois pas en quoi
ce que vous y êtes extrêmement important
celle enquêtes pisa quoi voir les deux
choses quoi résultats améliorés x et
ceram et comment il s'en ira parfaire le
vous interroger à nouveau
donc notre à porter opposé rapidement
des questions et les collègues
question qu'ils iront à vous poser parce
que vous nous avez fortement à former
bien informée oui il y en a qui sont
obligés de partir je suis désolé on
s'est un petit peu étendu ça serait bien
si et d'ici une demi-heure on pouvait
avoir terminé quoi oui merci monsieur le
président pour pour faire suite à ce que
vous n'êtes dirais pour répondre aussi à
quelques interrogations qu'on a eu en
aparté où je vous interromps chier
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière ces
questions ou qu'est ce qu'il faut lire
entre les vignes bas il se cache rien et
a rien à la lire entre les lignes
un car vous savez on ne pose aucune
logique on ne cherche pas de bouc
émissaire pour reprendre un terme à qui
a été évoqué et on ne veut surtout pas
opposer les uns aux autres ce serait la
pire des solutions
un que mon obsession ce n'est pas non
plus la seule maîtrise budgétaire même
si dans le contexte que chacun connaît
on ne peut pas ne pas être conscient de
cela mon obsession mais pour moi ce
n'est pas une dépense je le dis je suis
plus à l'un d'entre vous tout à l'heure
ce n'est pas une dépense est un
investissement
c'est même le meilleur investissement
qu'on puisse donner aujourd'hui à nos
jeunes mais il faut passer justement de
cette logique de de dépenses à cette
logique d'investissement mais qui dit
investissements dit résultats et qui dit
résultats des évaluations et mon
obsession aujourd'hui c'est clair
1 c'est faire en sorte un coup de sortir
de ces situations
aujourd'hui un fils d'ouvrier à 17 fois
moins de chance de préparer une grande
école qu'un fils de cadres supérieurs
aux draps fils d'enseignant c'est ça mon
obsession et à partir de là c'est moi
quand je prends cette mission d'être la
quatrième ou cinquième je fais dans des
domaines différents
j'ai aucun a priori et aucun tabou je me
lève la tête je connais rien qu en jeu
un jeu je pense truc là donc aujourd'hui
les questions et rien derrière c'est des
questions ouvertes
un conte souhaite bien sûr vous poser
parce que vous êtes les partenaires
premier du système éducatif et surtout
on tire pas des conclusions ou ne tirait
pas des conclusions des propos qu'on
peut avoir aujourd'hui ça les
conclusions on les tire à au moins
2 juin et on aura encore le temps vous
l'a dit tout à l'heure d'en discuter
alors je vous pose est quand même une
question une ou deux questions sur les
sujets abordés
on est dans une société qu'on le veuille
ou non aujourd'hui qui exige de l'art et
de la réactivité et de la souplesse et
je crois pas que ce système éducatif le
monde éducatif
puis s'il y échapper alors qu'on soit
très clair on va pas comparer avec le
monde de l'entreprise n'est pas
l'entreprise c'est clair je le dis et je
le répète mais la société elle exige
réactivité et souplesse et est ce que
l'organisation 1 2 du système
aujourd'hui qui est encore extrêmement
sensible centralisée même si ça a évolué
et la déconcentration
il ya eu la décentralisation ça peut
encore évoluer mais ça reste encore
extrêmement centralisé est ce que c'est
bien adaptés justement à cette réponse à
cette réactivité à cette souplesse qui
est exigée est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
certain nombre de freins ou de rigidité
qui existe et qu'il faudrait n'ont pas
levé comme ça parce que si c'est aussi
simple auront été levés depuis longtemps
mais essayer de réduire je pense à des
rigidités géographique un des rigidités
1 en termes de sites 1 qui se traduisent
derrière par des difficultés au niveau
des affectations au niveau des
remplacements des rigidités ou des gir
des frontières aussi avec les les
statuts on va pas ouvrir le débat là
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas faire évoluer
un petit peu les choses de façon à
améliorer la situation que que j'ai
évoqués et finalement est ce que ces
rigidités aussi elle contribue pas au
malaise ou au mal être des enseignants
ses carcans un contribue pas un petit
peu à cette situation de mal-être ou de
mal et ça c'est ma première question la
deuxième elle concerne plus
l'inspection je n'aime pas le terme
inspection j'ai à dire l'évaluation des
enseignants qui sortent par en peluche
est à dire un contrôle formel de la
réalimentation des programmes et que ça
devrait pas être plus j'allais dire un
accompagnement un conseil vis-à-vis des
enseignants joie beaucoup d'autres
questions
mais comme ces journées de la femme je
veux quand même les 501 et collègues
pour qu'elle puisse vous poser aussi des
questions par rapport à la réactivité à
la souplesse je vais revenir fils
tournée l'a évoqué tout à l'heure je
pense que il faut pas oublier de prendre
un élément en compte le temps le temps
de l'enfant de la croissance de l'enfant
et de l'apprentissage
ça n'est pas un temps qui se mesure en
seconde en minute ou en heure c'est un
temps qui se mesure en années
même en dizaines d'années bon donc une
fois qu'on est enfin tant qu'on n'est
pas sans fin il faut avoir ça en tête
c'est à dire que la graines que l'on
sème aujourd'hui on sait qu'on l'a
mesurera sur pisa dans dix ans bon on la
mesure à pas demain ni après demain donc
et on voit bien que les évolutions du
système sont des évolutions lentes dans
le temps sans doute peut-être parce que
le système est sans doute un peu rigide
mais enfin il est rigide à tous les
étages 1 je pense le système donc je me
voilà donc faut voir comment on peut
trouver du liant nous à l'unsa on pense
que des choses peuvent évoluer
mais enfin là aussi ça dépend de quelle
conception nat à dire que dans le cadre
d'un dialogue social d'un véritable
dialogue social dans lequel d'ailleurs
on met des choses à négocier sur la
table on pense qu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent avancer collectivement sur
l'évolution du système éducatif
le diagnostic aujourd'hui il est à peu
près posée il est d'ailleurs à peu près
partagé par l'ensemble de la communauté
halo 3 toujours mais voilà donc
maintenant il est peut-être temps de se
mettre autour d'une table et de ne pas
faire de l'école et de l'éducation un
enjeu idéologique parce que c'est quand
même de cela que l'on souffre dans ce
pays me semble-t-il
contrairement à d'autres pays qui sont
cités en exemple je pense pas aller ya
la finlande n'y a pas que la finlande où
on voit là on n'a pas eu de l'espagne
tout à l'heure l'espagne a fait
d'énormes progrès regarder ce qui se
passe au portugal le portugal fait
d'énormes progrès
sur les évolutions de son système
éducatif c'est bien peut-être aussi
parce que sur ces questions là on est en
capacité dans ces pays de trouver un
consensus national
je voudrais réagir sur deux choses d'une
part sur sur l'inspection parce que on
entend beaucoup de choses sur sur
l'inspection et j'ai lu bien entendu
avec beaucoup d'attention les différents
comptes rendus des audiences préalables
que vous avez tenus et à chaque fois on
revient une idée qui est une idée
partiellement vrai mais partiellement
seulement l'inspecteur croulerait sous
les tâches administratives
à tel point que finalement aujourd'hui
il n'accompagnerait pas à aucun moment
les équipes pédagogiques
je suis désolé c'est intégralement faut
certes je reconnais volontiers que
l'inspecteur croule sous les tâches paix
sous les tâches administratives c'est
certain mais en même temps il serait
complètement faux de prétendre que
l'inspecteur n'est pas en permanence à
l'heure actuelle au plus près du terrain
pour accompagner les équipes par rapport
au projet éducatif au projet pédagogique
qu'elle mette en place que ce soit dans
le premier et dans le second degré
sûrement pourrait-on mieux faire en
ayant moins de charges administratives
mais pour autant ne pensons pas qu
actuellement la préoccupation des
inspecteurs soin de répondre à ces
tâches administratives en oubliant
l'intérêt des écoles et des élèves
je crois qu'en permanence que selon
premier ou dans le second degré on à
cette préoccupation
le deuxième point que je voudrais
évoquer ce sont les lourdeurs qui existe
à l'heure actuelle à tous les échelons
du système éducatif
on a de la rigidité partout et le plus
gros du travail des inspecteurs comme
des chefs d'établissement d'ailleurs
bien souvent l'heure actuelle comme des
enseignants une certaine façon aussi
c'est d'essayer d'assouplir le système
en passant par les trous de souris
alors si on pouvait élargir un petit peu
ces trous de souris et faire des
boulevards qui permettent d'aider
vraiment les élèves à progresser au
mieux peut-être qu on avancerait plus
vite
à l'heure actuelle tout constitue un
frein travailler en liaison premier
second degré complexité immédiate
est ce qu'on ne va pas toucher au statut
respectives des uns et des autres
il arrive un moment où ça devient un peu
exaspérant parce qu'il arrive un moment
on se dit que si on était effectivement
mesure de travailler ensemble corps
d'encadrement chef d'établissement
directeur enseignant on serait sûrement
en mesure de progresser davantage
on découvre chaque année l'histoire des
élèves
tout se passe comme si les élèves
n'avaient aucune histoire leur histoire
elle est reconstruite chaque année
combien de fois l'enseignant se trouve
dans une situation où il dit en bas j'ai
découvert ceci et cela j'ai découvert
telle caractéristique de l'élève
c'était là il est suivi bien souvent
depuis l'école maternelle
il a été suivi tout au long de sa
scolarité élémentaire et on découvre les
difficultés quand ils arrivent au
collège c'est à dire que à la fin du
premier trimestre un enseignant de
collège j voilà le constat que j'ai
posée est ce qu'il n'aurait pas été plus
intéressant quand même de continuer à
accompagner cet élève dans sa scolarité
est ce que cette rupture supplémentaire
qu'on lui a fait subir alors même qu'il
était déjà en difficulté ne constitue
pas déjà une attaque grave contre ces
futurs droits de citoyens je crois
vraiment qu'on a à réfléchir à l'heure
actuelle en ces termes j'évoquais tout à
l'heure la porosité entre les
différentes les différents niveaux
d'enseignement
cette porosité à l'heure actuelle le
système semble s'ingénier à la bloquer
par tous les moyens
alors qu'il devrait probablement être
dans une situation il devrait essayer
d'ouvrir au contraire avec toujours une
seule et même préoccupation
l'intéressée elle oui je souhaiterais
rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être dit
parce qu'en effet ça nous paraît
fondamental de ne pas laisser les
enseignants seuls par rapport à des
difficultés et par rapport aux besoins
spécifiques des élèves et il est
important que les liait les personnels
qui qui puisse épauler par rapport aux
difficultés spécifiques ça soit parce
que l'enfant à handicap parce qu'il a un
problème de troubles d'apprentissage
parce que il a une situation sociale
particulière et donc pouvoir encore bien
tenir compte de lettres que peu importe
que peuvent apporter les les assistantes
sociales les infirmer les médecins qui
sont dans l'ombre mais dont le rôle
était
talent et on parlait des obligations de
service des enseignants mais il faut pas
oublier l'obligation des obligations de
service de service à rendre à la
population de ces personnels qui est
fondamental et il faut bien dire qu'à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui
leur mission dans leur ensemble sont
très difficiles a assuré et on voit avec
regret que des dix sites situations qui
pourraient être prévenus justement se
dégrade
est ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure où
une enfant n'a pas été signalé parce que
pour l'aps de temps il n'a pas pu être
suivis et il ya un trou et c'est anormal
alors qu'on le savait et qu'on aurait pu
aider d'enseignants et puis un deuxième
point par rapport à un accompagnement le
compte tenu de l'évolution des
législations 2005 2007 c'est les
exigences qui sont portées vis-à-vis des
enseignants sont quand même plus lourde
en termes de types de populations
accueillies et je souligne qu' il serait
quand même intéressant justement de voir
au niveau de t d est fait par rapport à
aux enseignants de ce qui se passe en
termes de risques psychosociaux ou en
risque de problèmes de travail et
actuellement nous allons toujours pas
une médecine de prévention de halal à la
hauteur de ce qui pourrait protéger les
enseignants pour la merci du président
mais oui une joue il est important de
savoir apporter des soins quand il y a
des blessés mais une chose aussi est
importante qu'il n'y ait pas de blessés
il est certain je romps prix peut-être
un petit peu avec un et des propos feu
très bon il est certain que si nous en
sommes un certain point avec les
résultats que vous évoquez très
justement sur la requête pisa qui elle
même peut être contestée qui peut
elle-même peut être revu c'est aussi
parce que nous sommes au terme d'un de
dindane est nombreuse où on a imposé un
système uniforme d'enseignement qui ne
convenait pas aux élèves qui étaient
générateur de refus de l'école qui était
le générateur de conflits entre des
familles et professeurs et qui font que
le professeur l'enseignant le peu le
maître d'école j'aime bien ce terme dans
son école le professeur dans son collège
dans son lit c'est aussi maintenant est
souvent l'objet vers lequel se tournent
l'agressivité public qu'elles soient
verbales morale physique ça c'est une
réalité qui est venu
fait qu'on a aussi abdiqué à certains
principes qui était celui de l'autorité
du maître que l'on devait conforter les
hiérarchies effectivement dans le
meilleur des cas fonctionne aux côtés
des professeurs mais dans bien des cas
ne le font ne le font pas ne soutiennent
pas c'est une réalité
on le sait on en est là on va le
dépasser moi j'en suis entièrement
d'accord et pour cela si monsieur le
rapporteur disent effectivement que rien
ne se cache derrière les les lignes qui
sont écrites je crois que vous avez tout
à fait raison dans la façon dont les
avait écrites mais ce qui se cache
derrière c'est toute une représentation
aujourd'hui présente dans dans le bruit
des représentations de notre société sur
l'école est effectivement qu'est ce que
l'on voit on voit un discours gagné par
par un vocabulaire un peu managériale on
voit une terminologie qui sen qui
s'impose on voit des idées qui se disent
inquiets s'insinue je crois qu'il est
temps de loin des finlandais par
parenthèse la finlande tout petit pays
qui a énormément de problèmes
d'immigration il y a beaucoup de suédois
en finlande petit pays aux systèmes
éducatifs idéal dans lequel dans les
cinq dernières années il y a eu quatre
cas de fusillades dans des
établissements scolaires
alors quand on parle de certaines choses
qu'on aille regarder partout hein donc
ce que je crois c'est que revenons qui
ont bien à 7 millions et alors je
reviens à cette idée là je crois que
notre notre solution c'est effectivement
de revisiter en profondeur ce qui a fait
le succès du système éducatif français
c'est à dire un service public de
qualité assis sur des professeurs
garanties et des personnels de tout des
personnels d'encadrement garantis par
des statuts nationaux assuré du soutien
de la société qui les emploie
parcours un ministère qui est essentiel
qui est quand même finalement ministère
public de l'avenir
1 et pour cela je crois qu'il faut se
installé dans ce que nous sommes et non
pas dans l allée voir ailleurs alors
dernière chose aussi oui effectivement
envoyé on dit on parlait de dix
parenthèse encore et en conclusion on
parler de dérive managériale tout à
l'heure on disait que les cadres doivent
être quand même des professeurs ça
pourrait on doit le rappeler le ça
concerne au premier rang les recteurs
vous le savez le statut a changé depuis
1854 il a changé il y a deux mois depuis
une les récentes réformes
le recteur et le seul serviteur de
l'éducation nationale qu'ils ne soient
astreints à aucune exigence de diplôme
il n'en a plus de la nécessité et
surtout il n'est plus ce qu'il devait
être autrefois un professeur au centre
universitaire docteur et et et et est
habilité à conduire des thèses c'est un
élément très important très important
merci
pardon excusez moi quitte à paraître
corporatiste puisqu'on a été interpellé
en tant qu'inspecteur moi je voudrais
simplement attirer votre attention
monsieur le président sur deux points
essentiels
les inspecteurs inspecteur d'académie
inspecteurs pédagogiques régionaux entre
autres n'ont plus les moyens d'effectuer
leurs missions puisque parlons chiffres
qui comprennent un premier euros par an
pour circuler pour intervenir dans des
académies qui sont grandes comme la
belgique c'est avoir les moyens pour
travailler environ deux mois deux mois
c'est à dire que nous reste du temps on
est condamné à rester au rectorat et
donc on fait de l'administratif bien
c'est pas toujours le cas mais c'est
souvent le cas par ailleurs en gros il
ya une espèce de 2,2 proverbe qui dit
que les hypers paye pour devenir
inspecteur c'est à dire qu'en fait on
seront rémunère l'état à travers nos
véhicules et c'est ce qui explique qu'
on ne puisse pas toujours aller voir les
professeurs puis deuxièmement et c'est
un point extrêmement important plus
important que le premier c'est que les
hypers les iade des tous les inspecteurs
sont en grande difficulté parce que tout
simplement lorsqu'il découvre que les
enseignants ont des difficultés ils
n'ont aucun moyen
mais ce qui s'appelle aucun moyens
financiers techniques matériels locaux
tout ce que vous voulez pour pouvoir
effectuer effectivement une remédiation
une réinsertion
disons pour remettre en place des
enseignants qui sont en difficulté
quant à la formation continue des
enseignants vous savez comme moi c'est
une peau de chagrin
alors comment imaginer un rapport
d'inspecteurs qui quitte un
établissement en disant ben voilà il
faudrait faire s'il faudrait faire ça
tout le monde est enthousiaste le chef
d'établissement est d'accord et quand il
faut suivre et mais y'a rien qui suit
puisqu'il n'y a aucun moyen et qu' il ya
encore quelques années les mavs peine
etc pouvait peut-être je suis prudent 1
pouvait peut-être financer un certain
nombre d'actions de formation depuis
quelques années on a complètement pompé
et la dernière en date étant vous le
savez que tous les moyens d'actions de
formation de cette année ont été pompés
il n'y a pas d'autre terme puisqu'on
était dans le vocabulaire maritime tout
à l'heure et bien par les nouveaux faux
stag les fameux fonctionnaires
stagiaires qu'on nous un peu
c'est un peu partout dans certaines
académies d'ailleurs d'une manière très
abusive dans la mienne 490 dans une
académie où les gens ont pas forcément
un facteur de réussite etc essentielle
on nous impose énormément et avec quoi
avec les moyens formation continue qui
étaient destinés à la remédiation des
collègues que nous trouvions dans
difficultés pour lesquelles nous avions
les solutions mais maintenant nous avons
des solutions mais ne vont pas d'argent
et je pense que ça c'est un problème
fondamental
je crois que la formation continue des
enseignants a été complètement négligé
par ailleurs tout à l'heure nous posions
la question du statut des enseignants
pourquoi est-ce que la formation
continue des enseignants pour époux est
inscrite dans leur statut
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce que là
on serait peut-être plus à même de
pouvoir répondre là et nous de ne pas
nous faire accuser d'être des feignants
n'est pas est ce parce que c'est un peu
ce qui est arrivé
1 et je pense que de ce côté là il
faudrait quand même remettre les
pendules à l'heure et dire entre autres
lorsque vous rencontrerez monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur le rapporteur que les les ja
hyper entre autres et les ja et les é u
n n'ont plus les moyens d'effectuer
leurs missions
parce que tout simplement nous n'avons
plus les moyens de circuler est aussi
bête que ça
on c'est normal la réunion était longue
et que j'étais avec un ravin on tombe un
peu d'engagés rédigeait le prévenu quand
même ça veut dire quoi
la mission d'action pour la forme bon
essayons essayons de rester dans ce
qu'on voudrait construire comme en voit
les choses etc
et nous on s'enfonce pas et des
revendications que je comprends
parfaitement
madame après monsieur nommé madame ici
monsieur là
oui je voudrais revenir très rapidement
sur ce que vous appelez les rigidités le
carcan du statut est ce que ça contribue
pas au mal être des enseignants
est-ce que c'est pas cette extrême
centralisation est ce que c'est
compatible avec ce monde moderne qui
nécessitent souplesse et réactivité
eh bien je vais vous répondre ce qu'on
répond toujours de toute façon ça sera
pas très nouveau dans notre discours
mais je vais essayer de démontrer
pourquoi on défend ce statut est
pourquoi pour nous ces prix de
l'efficacité
c'est ce que vous appelez des rigidités
c'est le prix à payer pour certaine
efficacité je prends quelques exemples
je prends l'exemple de la bivalence par
exemple qui est très sains
c'est un serpent de mer qui revient
souvent c'est sur si les enseignants du
second degré étaient en capacité
d'enseigner deux trois quatre
disciplines ça serait plus souple pour
aller mettre n'importe où n'importe
quand sauf que c'est pas forcément ça
l'efficacité
si on pouvait les affecter en dehors de
tout barème bas là aussi ce serait plus
souple on n'aurait pas s'embêter à
arrive à respecter un certain nombre de
règles on ne serait sûr de pouvoir
mettre n'importe qui n'importe où
boucher les trous comme on veut dans le
site antec on a le monde le monde
possible pour le faire mais bon c'est
pas tellement compatible disons avec
l'égalité des droits des personnes ni
tellement compatible non plus avec une
certaine indépendance du fonctionnaire
qui soient recrutés par le parce qu'il
est le copain de du fils de machin ou
quelques les la rigidité du barème
d'affectation des personnels lll
c'est le prix à payer pour un certain
nombre de garanties
vous parlez du remplacement par exemple
là on peut dire que les choses ont quand
même été considérablement assoupli ces
dernières
parce que les collègues qui étaient
d'abord il y avait un système de
remplacement qui fonctionnait pas si mal
que ça dans le second degré qui étaient
les tzr qui tend à disparaître les
titulaires sur zone de remplacement qui
tend à disparaître de plus en plus ses
collègues affectés sur une zone pour
aller remplacer les collègues en absent
pour maladie ou autres de courte durée
essentiellement ont vu les leurs zones
de remplacement de plus en plus élargie
là je peux vous dire que c'est pas
rigide c'est plutôt devenu très relax et
donc ils y font des kilomètres ils
peuvent être affectés sur des zones de
plus en plus grande donc ça on peut pas
dire que tu ailles et une rigidité très
vents de là dedans et quand même toute
façon maintenant il y en a d'autres mais
de moins en moins de deux titulaires
remplaçants ils ont été supprimés au fil
des emplois supprimés au budget et donc
ce sont des contractuels
quand il y en a qui fournit remplacement
est donc là aussi avoir des tzr c'est
une rigidité
c'est une rigidité mais c'est aussi la
garantie de pouvoir imposer à un
collègue d'aller faire leur emplacement
un endroit qui est pas desservi par les
transports en commun ou qu'un
établissement difficile alors que quand
vous n'avez pas ses collègues là sous la
main ben le vacataires ou contractuels
que vous allez payés au lance pierre
vous n'allez pas plus pouvoir lui
demander d'aller refaire un remplacement
dans un collège difficile qui se trouve
en plus avec pas de transport donc voilà
je voulais revenir soit 100 et 110 à
suivre est ce que je veux dire vous
interromps pose des questions etc
mais on avait beaucoup de gens on
connaît quand même un petit peu le sujet
oui mais bon on a eu l'occasion de on ne
retombons pas il faut que les statuts
des fonctionnaires serait suffisamment
protégé pour pas qu'ils soient à la
merci de ceux ci cela y compris du
citoyen mais il faut de l'autre côté que
le service puisse fonctionner mieux qu'
une souplesse et qui est des évolutions
qui se fasse bon on est tous dans un
dilemme là vous vous négociez dans vos
organisations syndicales vous voyez
votre côté les gouvernements voyez vous
à leurs côtés et c'est bon c'est c'est
un peu la discussion au fond c'est à
dire quand on vous pose la question sur
les statuts sur ce si sûr cela qu'est ce
que c'est que le le responsable d'un
établissement et cetera donc on revenons
pas au début de la discussion et le
sujet de la discussion
monsieur je suis désolé c'est s'excuser
mais c'est un petit peu je vais je vais
vous désobéir puisque mais je vais faire
très vite par contre un mois celle de
celle terme carcan qui m'a fait réagir
parce que enfin mettre mettre en avant
le carcan dans un contexte où j'ai le
g10 t1
depuis 2007 la profession premier degré
secondes et doit aussi est soumise à une
véritable plus d'enclumes donc dire que
ça manque de souplesse et de réactivité
quelque part ça me questionne a depuis
la rentrée 2007 passage à 24 +3
suppression du samedi matin et aide
personnalisée accompagnement éducatif
nouveau programme stages de remise à
niveau est clair référentiel de
compétences désirait une maternelle les
tice le plan sciences les langues
maternelles peut pas reprocher à la
profession doit être souple et réactive
et la profession elle
je dirais qu'elle a besoin de boussole
et que peut donner à la côte qu'est ce
qui peut donner à la profession une
boussole c'est la formation
et qu'est ce qu'on voit sur le pq lite
et la formation initiale qui est réduite
à rien on peut le dire comme ça et ça ça
me dérange je me pète caricatural mais
on peut pas le dire autrement la
formation continue on l'a dit qui est
quasiment inexistante
ça pose problème et il ya aussi une
incompréhension alors ça nous ramène un
petit peu au sujet plus précisément de
nos échanges mais comprend sont des
collègues quand les recteurs cherche des
gisements d'efficience dans les
académies les collègues ski ski ce
qu'ils voient c'est une nuit qualité sur
le territoire ici on va retirer sur des
postes de rased
ici on va retirer sûr on n'est pas dans
un cadre de d'égalité et les colonnes
ils le perçoivent ils le vivent mal et
c'est quelque part et ça laisse aller sa
les salaisons ferme aussi légère que
vous avez évoqué pisa tout à l'heure
mais en une phrase non je termine juste
après après je vous embête plus je vous
avais je crois que vous semblez de plus
après pisa le lot ces deux montrent que
la france a des as des as les résultats
qu'elle a des résultats moyens certes
mais que l'école maternelle a un effet
sur sur les résultats des élèves un
effet positif alors en termes de
politique
on marche sur la tête on a le c d e qui
nous indique connaît sur du positif
quand on scolarise de gants quand on
travaille sur le pré primaire et qu'on
scolarise la france la belgique et
israël sont cités et que fait qu'est ce
qu'on va en termes de politique
éducative en france au contraire on voit
un retrait sur l'école maternelle et une
école maternelle laissé en friche de
mots très rapide premièrement un constat
vous avez pu voir que l'attractivité du
métier d'enseignant se mesure à l'aune
du nombre de personnes qui passent le
concours
il a chuté colossalement faut
s'interroger même si le nombre de postes
mis au concours a chuté
deuxième constat que nous venons de
vérifier nous venons d'entamer les
logiques des mutations des personnels
les mutations les demandes de mutation
ont fondu dans notre secteur de manière
colossale pourquoi c'est tout simplement
la peur qu'on les collègues de se
retrouver le dernier arrivé dans un
établissement scolaire et donc de subir
s'il ya moins de moyens une carte de fun
carte scolaire
deuxième question qui est fondamentale
puisque ça n'a pas été évoquée mais
c'est quelque chose qui pour moi est
fondamental c'est la lisibilité de
l'école pour l'opinion et pour
effectivement les individus ça signifie
donc c'est la limite et les parcours et
ça pose une question qui n'a pas été
évoqué un mot qui est fondamental c'est
l'orientation et nous demandons donc ici
l'égalité des trois voies de formation
notamment la voie professionnelle qui ne
doit pas être une voix effectivement
ghettoïser qui doit être véritablement
pour ce qu'elle est et c'est pour ça que
nous sommes battus sur une logique de
parcours dans ces pays au bts avec la
logique des souplesses que vous
souhaitez mais qui ne doit pas être liée
à cette souplesse tel qu'on l'entend
comment effectivement ça a été dit très
logiquement un jeune doit pouvoir faire
le pas
cours en sortant du système avec le plus
haut niveau de qualification qu'il
puisse avoir c'est ça effectivement
puisque la nation nuit sur lui dans le
cadre du pacte social donc on passe aux
questions ici donc je vais essayer une
ce président d'être rapide
je vous ai toutes et tous écoutés mise à
part une sûreté ou deux épreuves de
téléphone mais d'autres sont sortis
aussi j'ai pas entendu qu'ils se soient
nous parler autrement qu'en disant qu'il
est insuffisant ou que l'on supprime des
postes ou qu'on fait parce qu'il faut du
montant réel du budget de l'éducation
nationale tels qu'ils figurent dans le
budget de la nation j'ai en mémoire un
chiffre je vous donne pas à faire les
premiers 60 milliards d'euros pour cette
année sur un budget qui doit être de 286
milliard d'euros alors monsieur
chevalier nous a dit tout à l'heure on
est que le budget en allemagne était en
augmentation il nous a pas dit combien
et par rapport à combien moi je vous
donne le montant du budget de
l'éducation nationale en 2011 pour 2011
60 meilleurs sur 286 milliard saillir en
gros 1 1 milliard pour 1,1 million
d'habitants est ce que le rapport que
vous avez cités tout à l'heure elle même
concernant l'allemagne j'aimerais bien
avoir ces à montaut poser une question
un élément c'est un point de détail mais
cette fois de détails importants et en
gros 80 millions d'habitants en
allemagne après la réunification sont
des chiffres approximatifs mais assez
proche de la réalité
ça permet de regarder par rapport un
pays comparable
l'allemagne 80 millions d'habitants par
rapport à la france 60 millions c'est
mieux que la comparaison avec la
finlande qu'on nous ressort à toutes les
réunions de la commission de l'éducation
sans arrêt on nous dit on en finlande
parce qu'une mission qui est allée bien
sûr ils font de belles choses en
finlande je le nie pas mais sept
millions d'habitants ne l'oublions pas
c'est pas tout à fait le même niveau et
la même échelle donc voilà ce que je
voulais dire c'était pas vraiment des
questions mais c'est simplement pour
donner des précisions sur lesquelles on
n'a pas entendu grand chose aujourd'hui
simplement on est deux couleurs
politiques évidemment diverses
veillez donc avoir un rapport que l'on
va construire le rapporteur va le
construire on va en discuter
on peut se trouver non mais je vous
donne la parole on va on peut se trouver
entre nous en désaccord est ce moi c'est
mentionné dans le rapport veut dire
qu'on soit et ils ont peu tombés
d'accord sur les conclusions mais c'est
pas nous qui remplaceront les ministres
qui vont se succéder ce magnifique
rapport que tu en as feydeau et tu sais
que des fois ils sont pas toujours
toujours utilisé et peuvent prendre leur
place dans une armoire et vous en
parlerez ensuite comme étant votre
expérience où il y avait eu cette
fameuse réunion était assez longtemps et
c'est ça va aboutir cette président avec
ta permission
j'ai commis un rapport il ya un peu plus
de deux ans maintenant ça passe vite sur
la formation professionnelle j'avais dit
à l'époque presque quatre ans ça passe
très vite
j'avais dit que j'avais dépassé l'âge de
faire des rapports pour venir enrichir
les rayons de la bibliothèque du sénat
comme j'ai pris quatre ans de plus donc
c'est encore d'autant plus grand donc
c'est le rapport nous allons produire on
verra bien c'est au mois de juin
ils ne viennent pas enrichir seulement
les rayons des bibliothèques du sénat
mais qu'ils servent tout ce qu'il en est
mais on ne peut pas tout à fait
travailler dans le même sens que nous
dit dernièrement mais on en tiendra
compte évidemment
mais ça tient plus de ça tient plus de
la remarque que tu un questionnement
parce que évidemment on est dans un
exercice de style qui pour nous est
extrêmement frustrant parce qu'on ne
peut pas être réactif par rapport à ce
que vous dites est donc en ce évidemment
conforme à la règle qui a été adopté
sinon on ne serait pas là bien entendu
lorsque je vais vous dire c'est que moi
je crois vraiment certains d'entre vous
l'ont dit d'ailleurs yens lassitude du
corps enseignant et il ya une perte de
repérage sur le sens de l'école pour les
enseignants et pour pour la population
dans sa globalité et je crois que vous
avez dit des choses très très importante
en tout cas qui pour moi nourrissent
vraiment ma réflexion et j'espère
évidemment de le faire valoir dans dans
le cadre de ce rapport sur la manière
dont on devrait expérimenter c'est à
dire que je crois qu'il faut qu'on sorte
de cette sorte de comportement erratique
qui consiste à engager une
expérimentation de pas vraiment l'avoir
préparé de la généraliser brutalement et
puis ensuite quelquefois peu de temps
avant après de revenir y compris sur
cette expérimentation ça je crois qu'il
faut arrêter tout ça je vais vite et
simplement pour dire que vous avez parlé
de d'engagement politique au sens où il
faudrait redéfinir le sens le sens de
l'école moi j'ai envie de dire on a
besoin d'un engagement politique
partagée c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
vraiment être en capacité dans ce pays à
partir des diagnostics qui sont réalisés
par les uns et par les autres et donc
d'ailleurs dont d'ailleurs pisa fait
partie s'agit pas de nier ce qui nous
est dit par tous et partout de 16 par
toutes ces enquêtes
mais à partir de ce diagnostic est bien
d'essayer donc de réfléchir avec
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
sur les pistes qui serait nécessaire
d'engager y compris par parler par
l'expérimentation
donc c'est ce que je voulais ce que je
voulais vous dire pour vous dire un peu
l'état d'esprit dans lequel nous nous
nous enfin pour ma part que je je suis
et j'en terminerai vraiment en dix ans
évidemment les contraintes budgétaires
qui sont imposés à l'école ne sont pas
de nature à permettre un débat serein et
non je crois que la première chose ça
serait de dire bon bah écoutez on se
pose est vraiment ensemble on travaille
et on a vite en inventant semble l'école
dont la france a besoin
je souhaitais dire c'est ne pas allonger
le débat inutilement mais je le partage
complètement
j'aurais simplement répondre au sénateur
humbert simplement pour l'allemagne on
est deux pays à peu près équivalent
visiblement les résultats scolaires de
l'allemagne n'ont pas été meilleures que
les résultats français à quelques années
puisque vous le savez l'allemagne a
choisi de refonder complètement son type
d'enseignement et à partir de là c'est
vrai que les choses se sont améliorées
mais est ce que les plus défavorisés qui
sont les turcs et qui sont au nombre de
sept millions 800 mille ont fait des
progrès ce semble-t-il pas du tout et
donc je crois que de ce côté là il
faudrait que c'était une de nos grandes
demandes nous que nous puissions
connaître plus profondément les méthodes
qui ont permis de réussir quels que
soient les pays dans le monde parce
qu'il ya pas que l'europe et voir aussi
quelles sont les contraintes qui sont
imposés parce qu'il ya un pays qui
réussit très bien c'est singapour
mais vous savez qu'ils ont tout
simplement réinventer la chicotte et je
pense que c'est pas forcément la
meilleure
j'ai rien affirmer j'attendais qu'on me
donne le chiffre du budget consacré à
l'éducation en allemagne fédérale
on ne l'a pas donnée donc je peux pas
comparer vous pouvez confirmer ce que
vous voulez je crois simplement que il
ya quand même 60 milliards dans le
budget de cette année pour la france oui
je souhaitais je souhaitais en baisse ce
soit et répondra à cette question
d'abord aux personnes ne nous a posé de
question et que nous sommes bien élevé
nous répondions question qu'on nous pose
est donc ce n'était pas l'objet en tous
les cas de l'audition effectivement 60
milliards 60 milliards sont dépensés le
rapport ducasse du sang dernier
stratégique donne toutes ces données
la france dépense plus tôt dans une
médiocre moyenne pas la plus mauvaise
mais pas la meilleure loin s'en faut
la part de son pib pour pour l'éducation
mois que les états unis par exemple
sensiblement moins que les états unis et
quand on ramène ça au nom aux élèves
puisque par bonheur nous avons des
générations relativement nombreuses par
rapport à par rapport à l'allemagne
la dépense à la tête ou mais franchement
dans le dernier tiers à peu près des
pays dont que nous dépensons beaucoup
d'argent c'est certain 60 milliards
c'est c'est une seule personne dit
contraires auxquels il faut ajouter les
engagements des conseils régionaux des
conseils généraux et des conseils
municipaux enfin vers cela
semant personne ne dit mais quand on
regarde le fond marin international
puisque ces données existent la france
ne fait pas d'effort particulier elle ne
fait pas elle n'est pas le dernier des
pays mais on peut comparer que des pays
comparables y compris un pays qui ne
passe pas pour être particulièrement un
soutien et les des services publics je
pense à la grande bretagne fait
aujourd'hui des efforts beaucoup plus
considérables que la france en matière
d'éducation et dans pisa ça se voit bien
aider vraiment ses pilotes pour la mise
en oeuvre des helvètes qui seront
obligatoires en 2015
mais voilà voilà effectivement vous
faites comme nous alors nous ça fait
longtemps qu'on ne découvre pas le sujet
mais je vous informe que la france est
pilote dans le cadre de l'enseignement
professionnel pour la mise en place des
svts or l'acronyme européen
vous allez mon excuse et ckoi ma caméra
l'angliciste ça s'appelle european
credits fabrication de l'éducation donc
à partir de là je vous l'apprends et
c'est un singe et un sujet qui est très
important puisque c'est comment les
citoyens et les salariés vont pouvoir
bouger dans l'europe
les helvètes se met en place et seront
obligatoires dans toute l'europe en 2015
la france en est pilote bonne nouvelle
oui trois formations professionnelles
merci pour votre gentillesse rester et
déjà 18h25 et donc ça on a beau aller
vite c'est difficile que tout le monde
puisse s'exprimer valablement
suffisamment
vous venez de suivre la table ronde
organisée par la mission commune
d'information sur l'organisation
territoriale du système scolaire
une mission présidée par le sénateur
socialiste serge lagauche qui rendra ses
conclusions au mois de juin
cet après-midi la libye sera au coeur de
l'actualité sénatoriales une déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat aura
lieu dans l'hémicycle
un événement que vous pourrez bien sûr
suivre en direct sur public sénat à
partir de 17h est très bonne journée